tough over zoom to get shitty jokes
across because you get
[Laughter]
you never know believe me when i say i
completely understand it's especially
great when you're talking to like three
people
doing like a tribeca interview and each
person tries to
over you know talk over each other and
then they don't know who's talking
it's it's [ __ ] awful you have to go
hey everyone wait stop talking for a
second i got a joke
can everyone hear me three two here
comes my joke
which is a really great way to present
humor
yeah it's a disaster so i got uh i have
like 15 minutes with you so i'm going to
work in a
few different types of questions i want
to start with
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
all in the family is it too late am i
too late for that one
well if they do another live episode you
might be able to take a crack at it
you know taxi taxi i want to do taxi i
want to do
i want to work with judd hirsch and mary
lou henner um
tony the dance of course uh devito
that's what i don't want to do i like i
like taxi
oh by the way why wouldn't you yeah joe
it really was like each episode was like
a
22 minute play with a great setting and
a really fantastic cast i'm actually
talking i was joking
sort of at first but it's actually one
of my favorite shows i love it
i love that whole cast was amazing and
sometimes look at that go man that must
have been such a great job
yeah i can only imagine actually also
you know anyway that's a whole i could
open the door and
just talk about that what movie or
movies do you think you've seen the most
uh the goonies
more than any other movie for sure there
was
a summer when i would just wake up in
the morning press play and it was over
and over and over again
all day for the entire summer and i
still find
lovely gems in that movie there's still
i still have a question about
that movie which is very confusing um
corey feldman who plays mouth
is his purpose on that journey is that
he translates the map from spanish
into english something that you might
not realize the first time watching it
is
he's translating it um and
it rhymes in english why would
these spanish people writing the map
have in their heads translated knowing
that someday somebody might translate
this to english and wouldn't that be
neat if it rhymes that doesn't really
make sense
i've seen the goonies a lot and i've
never realized that
it's kind of strange as someone i love
the goonies
like you do you want to see a sequel are
you one of these people that because
they've been talking about doing one for
a long time
i remember when it was like oh they're
gonna do one at the 15 year
and then when it was 20 years and
there's going to be these sequels
i'm i'm on uh both camps with that one i
would
love to see that happen again but i also
feel like don't touch it it's
perfect it is the best kids movie ever
made
and if they d i'm more interested to see
like that cast do something almost
something
else i feel like i would like to see the
cast of the goonies do the next
expandables movie
sure that's not what i was expecting but
sure
kind of the next oceans movie is that
better no i mean
i get what you're saying um i will say i
i love that movie that movie means a lot
to me
and if they do a sequel they better do
it right it's but no matter how right
they get it
it's never going to live up to what we
feel like looking back at that 1985
movie that feel it was just
perfect i don't know what you can do
another goonies with another set of
brilliant
kid actors or you're gonna do
something else with the cast are you
gonna do sort of a half and half are
they the parents now
see that that's the thing i think it i
think it would have to be there the
parents
their kids have to go on a mission and
the parents are relegated to like being
the c storyline or the b storyline um
i mean i have i have a listen i could
talk about the goonies non-stop i have a
lot
of parents like they're parenting
because they want to keep their kids
safe they're trying to be good with
parents but
maybe they have to realize that it's not
their time yes it's
their time it's their time down there
yes exactly
um so moving on to something else again
i could talk about the goonies non-stop
um
i love scott pilgrim versus the world
just
love and uh you know it just came back
edgar's been doing like these dolby
screenings
which uh uh listen anything that to talk
about scott pilgrim is a great thing so
what do you remember about making the
film
uh and what what can you share that you
remember about working with edgar and
the rest of the cast
it was great it was i kind of got away
with murder on that one
um because i think it was like a seven
eight possibly nine month long shoot i
was there for the first three months
when everyone was just like super
excited and then i was out
i was also the only main cast member
that didn't have to learn an instrument
or do any fight choreography training
whatsoever
so i just would they would have to get
up at 4am to do
fight training and then like play their
instruments and then show up and do 12
hour day of shooting and then
i would just like sleep in go out
go to a bar it was nice um
but and i was also i i joined like last
second and
uh man i'm really glad i did i made a
lot of friends
on that one and i really loved the
project um
edgar is really fascinating uh i did i
just
talked about this a couple of minutes
ago someone else but like he
had the entire movie in his head it
wasn't exactly you know
storyboarded um it was in his noggin
and it was already done like he had the
music cues he had the edits he had
exactly the way
the character was to turn their head
when they say they're like he had it
he just had to go through the tedious
motions
of actually filming it um no i actually
think he loves it he loves
making he was so excited he was like a
little kid making like
at play the whole time so his energy was
um
really was great for everyone to work
off of
i had the freedom to sort of be a little
more loose a bit so again i got away
with murder
and i the most fun playing that
character
yeah i've watched that film uh an
ungodly amount of times
um just a lot um
so jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you today first congratulations
on the movie
movie is so good um what is it like
finding out that soderbergh
wants you to be in his mood
uh yeah that's pretty cool
yeah no yeah that's
no but to me what's funny is i don't
like work that way i i don't go you know
i
i know his work and i admire his work
but i don't
you know i don't know i just don't try
to get into a film that
a filmmaker that i admire is making it
needs to fit
and i thought that i could play this
character and i really liked the script
um i thought i might have to audition
the fact that it didn't was pretty swell
i don't know if he knew that if he said
you know you have to audition i could
have and maybe he would have hired
somebody else
um but i'm
into place in a really lovely way isn't
that pretty swell
do you know what i mean like cause i
think some people go like oh i really
want to work with so and so and i don't
care what it is
sure absolutely and i don't
have that i was like it needs i needs to
be
something that i feel like i can do and
then if it happens to be with somebody
that i really admire i think that's
pretty great
same with like actors signing on it's
like
in this one in particular started seeing
a great cast signing on i thought well
that's a bonus
to something that i already said i
wanted to do like that's great
yeah completely what do you listen i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about
us making a soda berg movie
might surprise people um i don't know
what sort of
uh expectations people have to me it was
very like handmade and a little more on
the spot than i would have thought it
was like
we we have a script that we all really
like and trust and then there was just
sort of a lot of trust going on between
people that had
more or less just met each other and the
actors would very quickly rehearse
if there was an issue it would be talked
about briefly we come up with a quick
solution
stephen would say hand me a camera he
would shoot it
fast like one two takes here move around
well then i swear within an hour a scene
is done
and then our days would be short i don't
know if that was for cobit or because
the way stephen wanted to shoot but we
would shoot
very short days and then he would spend
the second half of that day
epic the moon so
by the time i left he showed me a really
good chunk of the movie
already cut together so i already had a
sense of what we were doing
um which is fascinating and i love that
because you know
it's very different from the way as i
talked about the way edgar wright works
very very different
um both a lot of fun because both
involve
a lot of trust in someone's vision in
the case of like edgar
it's a very specific vision that he
wants this movie to look like this and
you have to give yourself over to that
and that's pretty great
uh and then in the case of stephen it's
i want all of us to make this movie
and we kind of lean on each other and
trust each other knowing that he's sort
of captaining the ship in a way that we
all trust
it's very interesting because i was
talking to don and benicio yesterday
about how
steven works incredibly fast and you
know like you said like an hour two
hours
you're done with the scene and then you
have someone like david fincher
who does so many takes but they both
uh the both end results with both
filmmakers are fantastic movies
people have different processes in it
like i think like the reason i brought
up those two extremes is
they can both be great if you give
yourself over to it
there shouldn't be one way in which you
work
because everybody works so differently
and i think it's really great to just
sort of give yourself over to the
process you just gotta
i've been fortunate enough to work with
directors that actually have
talent and vision and i can go i trust
you
and then i feel good being in their
hands
is that thanos behind you it yeah it is
cool yeah there's a lot of stuff there
it's all distractions from this
right this isn't so bad either you know
i mean i think the toys are a little bit
better i mean i have notes
but i'll email them to you later about
how you can you know
i appreciate that please let me know
anything anything that can be done to
improve
will be a benefit um one of the things
one of the listen i love this is this
running danger field
uh it is yeah okay for a second it also
looked like an old ric flair
no it's right it's rodney
yeah that's right cool uh so what listen
i loved ed solomon's script
and i think that the way he weaves in
real history
into this crime caper is so well done
can you talk a little bit about
uh what you responded to with the with
the script that's
so tough for me to do
um i've brought this up a couple of
times but uh today in these little
this little press jacket thing um but i
feel like whenever
something doesn't work i have all the
words for why it doesn't work
and when something clicks or works i
don't
my brain does why it just goes yeah yeah
i like it i want to do it um
so in terms of what i felt like i could
play this part
and i really liked it i can't really
give
you insight into why like i i'm not a
writer i couldn't
buy what he did when he put it together
that made it
work so well and made it such a breeze
to read
and kept me engaged the entire time
i'm almost out of time and as a huge fan
of succession i definitely want to ask
you
are you in italy for vacation or for
succession
for succession we're we're
shooting the scene right before thanos
goes like this
and tom oneganz turns to ash and most
the rory family does except for roman
and um so i'm the only one signed on for
season four as far as i know
uh i have to head way star
when half the population has turned to
dust but it's fine
that's that's a great answer um uh
actually
being serious what can you for fans of
the series
um are you almost done filming uh what
can you tease about the season
uh probably nothing um we're about to
shoot the last two episodes out here
uh and i don't think i can tell you
anything i don't even know when the air
date is i know like a projected
goal but nobody really knows any of that
stuff we don't really get
like our episodes until we start
shooting them
so we don't often know um so
i know i'll remember at the beginning of
this interview i said what tv series
would you like to guest star on
so when i ask actors this i i speak to a
lot of actors
i think like 90 of people say succession
so
what is it what is it about these
terrible flawed rich people
that makes them so engrossing and um
does it bring you joy to know that
everyone
wants to work uh with the you know the
roy family
that's pretty cool um i'll tell you it's
even when we were shooting it i remember
thinking yeah it's great material i love
playing this character but
but why is anyone gonna want to watch
this show why
we're gonna want to get engaged in these
characters um
and i still felt that way for the first
few episodes that we started shooting in
the first season and somewhere around
shooting episode five or six i remember
coming home and saying to my wife
i was like i think we might have
something here she's like really i was
like i don't know why
but i really care to see what happens to
these people and i still haven't figured
out why that is
um and i'm a fan of the show so i watch
it like when we get scripts i'm a fan
i'm excited to see what's going to
happen with them i don't know why that
is and where that comes from um
but and terms are very cool but also
it's a
dream for us as actors working on it um
we show up we're getting the most
brilliant material
to work with just these scripts are
great and we get there on the day
and it's very similar to how we did
uh no sudden move in that it's
made it's we have half a day to make the
scene work
this room is a quarter of the size we
thought it was going to be
go and sometimes there's problems and we
don't have it and we have to ask props
and then they they
come up with a solution and the writers
have pages of like outlines or ways that
we can fix it and you just
you're on the spot and you just throw
things at each other and we do whole
takes we'll do
those long scenes that are sometimes
like eight nine ten minutes long we do
them all in one go like we would a play
and we often don't know where the camera
is
so everyone's on there's no like
coverage there's no like
over-the-shoulder setup shot
there's everyone is doing the scene
cameras are catching bits wherever
they're catching it it's
just it's it's freedom and they're not
on my ass about continuity and stuff
like that either so you can just sort of
be free to keep exploring what the
character's doing
and how they're interacting with each
other and
and again the camera department to have
the same kind of freedom
the camera readers sort of freely work
together and we find what the scene is
about while we're in it so it's a drink
yeah listen for an actor i don't know
how much of that i got cut out
a little bit my wi-fi is terrible i have
noticed it goes in and out
listen i gotta stop there i'm just gonna
say enjoy being in italy
thank you so much for your time and
congrats on no sudden move
it's fantastic
goonies never say die